my name is Michael che from Saturday
Night Live and I'm on set at G Q that's
my signature move needs work
favorites sketch of all time um like SNL
sketch I really like Adam Sandler it's
not really a sketch but Adam sailing on
an update is opera man I was thought
that was really funny they're just
always make you laugh the Eddie Murphy
one where he goes in Whiteface basically
and he like has a day in the life is a
white person because I remember seeing
that as a child and thinking it was an
actual documentary like think thinking
this is something that really happened
some of those Will Ferrell sketches I
don't know which one I would single out
Neil Diamond storytellers where he like
killed a drifter and then wrote Sweet
Caroline I was like oh my god I love
that get off the shed the Will Ferrell
sketch I love that one I also love the
one where he's at dinner and he's he's
with his family and they're like
disrespecting him and just the one where
he's the dad to at dinner
yelling about how he drives a Dodge
Stratus Eddie Murphy and Joe Piscopo
doing fudge and Solomon it's not as
popular as most vetti Murphy stuff but
it's really cool because they had a lot
of heart as kind of a sweet thing about
this old man was always down on his luck
I had a really good sense of humor and
Joe Piscopo played the piano play at a
bar for more videos like this subscribe
to the GQ channel should be a link right
there or however you gathered it comes